foi você é quantas vezes o verde o
cantor usa o ator diz pessoal de quem
fala é dar que sejam muito bem vindos a
mais um vídeo e ou estragos e que faca
que encontra exclusivos
nós vamos fazer aqui um teste da faca
quente quanto exclusivos para eu
conseguir arranjar é 71 obviamente que
isto é uma tentativa da área mas eu
inseri um de que os pauzinhos aqui que
os pacientes que fazem feliz que sabe
mas também comprei exclusivos reais
podem mesmo eu comprei muitos positivo
mesmo na introdução este não são
exclusivos que eu andei à procura nem
mas não consegui encontrar este aqui são
tipos inclusive para usar a pistola olha
aí eu comprei de oito de 12 eu acho que
este é o 12 dentro este é o barulho é
exclusivo para aí agora com exclusivo
acho que já deu pra perceber né eu vou
juntar este inclusive estou devo tentar
deter com a faca
eu também comprei aqui uns pauzinhos de
perfumes que sabe aquelas fez que vocês
metem em cima do bolo é que o tempo
fique isolado é mais além disso e eu vou
tentar acender todas ao mesmo tempo e
ver o que acontece
o movimento usando facchinetti já sabem
pessoal nunca façam isso em casa não
tentem nunca está em casa e agora está
na hora de colocar os nossos lucros
porque segurança acima de tudo né
[Música]
vejam só não comprei uma faca nova está
muito mais enfiado resposta me testar
faca e foi perguntar cargo e ela é mais
fininha e é por isso que eu comprei
porque ela deve aquecer mais rápido né e
olha só a lâmina meu tá muito afiada é
por isso é importante usar sempre luva e
vamos lá ver se ela não tá bom né
[Música]
ok pessoal já constará que seja a ficar
com aquela cor assim a zoada mãe
castanhos a olha lá fica muito quente já
milgrau a parceria ou assim é que é
muito mais rápido ela
eu acho que é melhor tirar isso daqui
meta de produção
vamos fazer a contagem 3 21 vai tudo
tudo tudo tudo fazer força
nem todo fazer força ó já parou de
cortar brutal eu fiz
imagina se fosse uma certeza o poste que
ganhava lá agora vamos tentar acender o
brasil duela com a faca quente só tentar
arrancar o clássico não está muito
animado ainda sentir o que depois do pan
é muito arriscado não faço em casa por
favor 3 2 1
o brasil foi roubada de bola de ouro não
só como é que ficou viúva ou toalhas ou
queimando de fumo que se uma chama verde
por também entrou que põe sou fã do
pulmão depois o bota foi que eu estava
muito fumo aqui mas não como fica a
nossa tnt pessoal eu sei como o pauzinho
é verdade mas eu nunca imaginei que o
fundo se isso mesmo ver no futuro
queimada que os fios aqui e isso é um
aspecto final o pessoal da nossa tenta e
óbvia ficou assim toda destruída agora
vamos passar ou exclusivos reais
já tivemos aqui alguns positivos para a
pistola por ser alguns pacotes já estão
abertos mas eu acho que é suficiente
para conseguirmos fazer alguma coisa
interessante que já tem 246
eu acho que a embalagem tem 96
exclusivos né 96 mesmo 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 18 19 e vou dizer que outro
20 é muito exclusivo à esquerda robinho
tem dois exclusivos e 12 vezes 20
equivalia a 240 exclusivo só que eu não
vou usar o registro já é muito
eu vou deixar que a água porque alguma
coisa acontecer é só mandar tudo pra mim
e pra cá mas o fogo nem qualquer só vou
fazer um teste primeiro inclusive a
ampliação e depois eu vou tentar fazer o
motor co institute e ver o que acontece
aqui
agora eu não sei se exporta apenas com o
impacto o ciclo também com uma ligação
tipo com uma faca que então assim é isso
que nós vamos ver só em 32 anos o seu
poste com tudo e manteiga
vocês têm que fazer fundo tem que fazer
fumo ler assistir esse fundo aqui olha
só como é que ficou por aí
no total eu falei bebê tinha a mesma
coisa juntos e repetir ó chi chuan jamal
só vamos usar uma tela que ver o que
acontece' 32 não funciona é é que ela
tem que ser uma coisa mais força nessa
eu acho que vai 321 pai não funciona
eu vou tentar algo no chão
ai pois funciona
eu acho que tem que ser mesmo em
superfície dura deixam assim eu acho que
isso vai ser muito uma ideia uma coisa
merece respeito fumo imagine uma torre
inteiro né ai ai não não eu ia ser muito
macho para boston eu acho uma boa idéia
com dois primeiros só com 2 dia então só
vamos tentar com dois de ver a
quantidade de fundo vai sair sair muitos
um eu não vou arriscar fazer com isso
tudo não há parâmetros para né a cápsula
teve uma ideia que a faz funcionar o
nosso problema eu tenho aqui um super
duro de qualquer coisa eu acho que só
pra arn que então o que eu vou fazer
para evitar confundir pai todo eu vou
tentar chegar a um fim com esta parte
vai ser excluído por aqui então eu acho
que vou conseguir controlar um pouquinho
fundo mas resulta 321 vai vai assinar
tudo e só vou tentar marcar uma torre
ver o que acontece
lá foi pessoal vamos lá tentar macular
ic32 um pai
3 eu sabia que tinha que acontecer em
julho
agora vou fazer uma turnê 4 ou fez valer
seu time movido eu vou tentar pôr um
exclusivo à frente uma sereia que ver o
que acontece' 3218 alencar agora
analisará em casa do que vocês vão fazer
é deixar um passo é deixar a vossa
subscrição e procurar este vídeo com
carne de pato e populares trio com o
nome nosso outra coisa pessoal faz te
punir é uma paulo brasília que tem ali
dentro o que eu vou fazer agora é tentar
arrancar essa paulo brasília e depois é
esse sim eu vou usar a faca e ver o que
acontece
só soube que esta pólvora isso é o que
faz com explosivos rebentaram e eu vou
tentar arrancar todas as cozinhas destas
de dentro do exclusivos e tentar queimar
com faca um senhor já
[Música]
ae oi
como assim respondeu tipo dill o brasil
uniu todos podem todos solo já tinha
último um estudo exclusivo saque ok
reunir os e por reinventar um perto de
alguns comentaram todos meu deus rouba
suas vocês só querem alguma forma
engraçada de utilizar que este
exclusivos comentem embaixo eu vou usar
e agora vamos passar então aos pauzinhos
incandescentes seu erro assim eu acho
que não
tudo por aí
aqui não aqui neste dia tomar tudo não
sabe o que é ser um espaço muito com
meus isso aqui é o cadu fez já que eu
fui imagine isso tudo não esqueçam
esqueçam eu não posso fazer coisas de
que explosivos pessoal é meta é o
seguinte nós conseguirmos chegar aos 150
mil likes neste vídeo eu vou tentar
fazer uma bomba caseira exclusiva a
melhor bunda exclusiva que será que eu
conseguir fazer mas vou explodir lá fora
eu caí querendo já vi que não dava mil é
muito fumo mas eles já sabem pessoal
150m light eo faça melhor bunda
exclusiva queda ainda que vocês já viram
na nossa vida aqui do nosso lado vocês
têm dois filhos que provavelmente não
viram tanto podem ver e graves e aqui em
cima vocês podem subscrever até o final
da franquia e ver mais com essa frase
que o fmi vai até a próxima